so this is always a very fun part of our
conferences
it's uh usually it's done
uh in person and usually i'm uh
trying to speed eat some food so we can
get going with it
things are different today we are going
to be
giving out our annual wolfram innovator
awards
uh recognizing people who've done really
interesting things with our technology
you know i built our whole technology
stack in part because i wanted to use it
myself
and i have a lot of fun doing that and
i'm always a little bit
uh envious of all the things that i see
other people doing
without technology because there's so
many really really cool things
i had a chance to a few few of the
people who
are receiving awards tonight i i already
knew
i had a chance to meet everybody earlier
today and that was a pleasure
um so what i'm going to do is
present these awards and i'm going to
say a little bit about each person
and so i will apologize in advance if i
get a bunch of stuff wrong and people
can correct that um
later or on chat or something but i
wanted to try and tell you a little bit
about um
what some of the projects that some uh
folks that we're recognizing tonight
here
um have uh have done and we're gonna go
through the uh
for people's logistical benefit we're
going to go through
in uh alphabetical order of last names
so uh without further ado
let me uh go to our first um i hope i'm
successfully sharing my screen here
our first uh innovator reward of the
evening is going to pedro balbi
mckenzie university in brazil i first
met pedro when he came to our
2003 nks summer school
that was started just after
my big book new kind of science came out
and
pedro worked on cellular automata there
he'd been his background was that um
he'd originally got an
electrical engineering degree in brazil
um then
applied computing master's degree then a
phd in cognitive science
at the university of sussex in england
uh
in 1995 and then had been a postdoc in
canada
he came to our uh summer school and
worked on
uh problems of kind of matching
evolutionary computation
with the kinds of things that we tried
to do with cellular automata
and he's been particularly interested uh
since that time
in making cellular automata compute
interesting things
and in fact he's had i think as many as
50 students all together
at mackenzie university in sao paulo
who've worked
on things related to cellular automata
with him
i think a problem of particular interest
has been
problem of taking of having a cellular
automaton which has lots of cells
which are all operating separately in
parallel
having the cellular automaton be able to
sort of collectively answer a question
so an example is the parity question are
there an even or odd number of black
cells
in the initial condition for cellular
automaton and palo was just telling me
today about new progress recently made
um in solving that problem on
generalizations of cellular automata
that involve not just synchronous but
asynchronous updating
on on graphs and so on so
uh paulo who's uh i had the pleasure of
uh
uh visiting with with paolo at his
university in in sao paulo uh
um in uh summer of 2018 and got to see
uh
uh some of the labs that they have there
and uh through paolo's work
every electrical engineering graduate
student for example at the university
is exposed to wolverine language and
also exposed to cellular automata
um and uh that's that's a really nice
thing to see
i think also paolo has been involved in
organizing
uh the automata uh family of conferences
which i i
happen to attend uh recently virtually
um as well as producing
a wolfram language cellular automaton
toolbox which is uh
available freely so our first award for
the evening
goes to pedro belby
and i think the the theory of this is
that here we go i hand this this way and
pedro
does that
thanks a lot stephen many thanks
i'm honored thank you thank you
all right let's see so our
next innovator award of the evening goes
to
kenneth bogan uh kenneth is in uh
um uh maryland um
and he is a toxicologist with a long and
interesting history
um first got exposed to our technology
on next computers he was a scientist at
lawrence livermore lab
and uh back when nexts were
new probably in 1989 um
uh kenneth got um started to use uh
mathematica on the next computer
and um he was involved in
assessing risks associated with
various kinds of public health things to
do with um
tumor-inducing agents and um and
other things and at that time he tells
me he started building
a uh a package called risk queue which
is kind of a pun
on the wolfram language convention of
using q at the end of functions that ask
a question
so risk q is kind of asking is there a
risk associated with something
and uh kenneth to give his background
got a bachelor's degree in biology at
princeton
masters degree in science technology and
public policy at george washington
university
and then master of public health and
doctor of public health and
environmental health science at uc
berkeley
and from from there went to lawrence
livermore lab where he worked for about
20 years
following that 10 years at um
consulting firm uh consulting on
uh health risk assessments in a variety
of different
settings um i think um
i was uh struck by seeing let's see if i
can pull up
yes it seems as if the um the the
the activity of being uh kenneth is a
board-certified toxicologist
it seems this is a very interesting
mixture of kind of statistical analysis
um of uh taking studies that have been
done
of uh particular kinds of risks together
with
actual physical modeling of things so i
i noticed um
in kenneth's body of work modeling of
the
human nasal cavity to study the effects
of to do with predicting zinc ion
diffusion
within the mucosa in in the human nose
uh kenneth was actually telling me today
that in addition to his work in
toxicology
um he's been very interested in the uh
sort of fundamental science of cancer
and actually has developed a kind of new
hypothesis
about uh the way that cancer is
initiated
that uh relates to um uh the
process of inflammation that happens he
has a
hypothesis that uh inflammation is is um
is key to the the initiation of um
cancer events in cells and uh
i think kenneth is something of an
expert on inflammation and um
as some of you know in the really bad
cases of covid
one of the things that can happen is a
so-called cytokine storm
that leads to a sort of runaway um
informational response and uh
kenneth has has been doing work recently
in connection with that
in connection with the uh pandemic i'm
looking at some lots of other
interesting examples of kenneth's work
here but
um uh i think we just should just uh
present kenneth with um
uh 2020 uh well from innovator award
well thank you so much
uh stephen you're uh thanks
thanks very much hi patrick all right
let's see
our next award is going to
thomas de camino so thomas
has a very eclectic background um
he's based in costa rica he's been
involved in many different things
he uh kind of um started
life as a biologist
uh first studying costa rica then
getting his phd in mathematical biology
at the university of alberta
um somewhere in the middle of that
getting a master's degree in computer
science
um also in in costa rica uh as
part of that master's degree um created
a language for programming cellular
automata
with applications in biology um his phd
was on biological control and um case
study with scentless chamomile
uh thomas tells us his first experience
with wolfram language was using
mathematica 4.0 back in the year 2000
for doing spatial analysis of satellite
images
then for working on matrix population
models and with differential equations
describing
uh population dynamics and so on um
needless to say maybe i jump ahead in
the story anybody who studied
population dynamics with differential
equations is likely to have been called
into action
in this past year because uh the
equations of epidemiology are the same
kinds of equations
but in any case thomas uh used
mathematica morphing language
in teaching computer science automata
theory
also made use of our capability to
connect to arduino microcontrollers
and uh has been very involved in in
costa rica
and the development of the maker
movement there in the
in the ability for to have um
uh students be able to actually build
things with 3d printing and so on and go
from the digital to the to the physical
in addition to
his other activities uh thomas has also
been
a music producer produced more than 60
albums of costa rican and central
american
musicians and has created a digital
record label with a new business model
and the
name of the label is automata records
that's a really cool name
he's also produced some of his own music
um using
electronic instruments that he's created
using algorithmic methods
so in the in the um current times
of um uh of covert thomas said
he thinks he might be the only
mathematical biologist in costa rica
so quickly got involved in being
interviewed
and being called in to help uh
with government policy in costa rica um
doing sir modeling to predict
epidemics the the growth of the epidemic
and so on
and uh he tells me that um
uh he's one of those people who has had
a chance to
actually use wolfram language live in uh
media interviews that's something i
always enjoy doing
um to uh explore aspects of uh of the
pandemic
and its consequences so he's also been
recently um involved in the
the spreading of kind of uh computer
technology
and maker technology within costa rica
not only using microcontrollers but also
a pilot project using raspberry prize
with wolfram language
um as a computer to provide to students
in a distance learning
university where in addition to giving
students books
to study with um he's had a chance to
get them given raspberry pies so that
they can
do do computation as well as read from
books
so our next innovator award of the
evening goes to
thomas de camino
thank you very much
all right our next uh
award for the evening uh goes to brandel
feitelson of northeastern university and
i've known brandon for
some years he uh he's a philosophy
professor
um it's uh and i'm uh
he does a lot of interesting things in
applying
computation to philosophy i think he's
was very early
in the world of being a computational
philosopher
he uh got um uh his bachelor's degree in
mathematics at university of wisconsin
and his phd
also at university of wisconsin in in
philosophy
um even from the time when uh he started
using
wolfram language and mathematica for his
thesis project back in 1994
and uh uh really uh i think
um he tells me that a lot of what he's
done
has been enabled by a lot of work that
we did in algebraic computation
particularly the creation of the reduce
and resolve
functionality in immortal language
that allow one to take arbitrary systems
of polynomial equations and inequalities
and be able to uh to algorithmically
resolve them
we were very proud of that term
technology and it's just wonderful to
see that a computational philosopher
is one of the beneficiaries of that
activity brandon has been
particularly concerned with trying to
sort of rewrite
some of the foundations of the way that
logic
is thought about you know logic is an
old business going back to aristotle in
the
you know fourth century bc or so um
but uh uh the the sort of modern
version of of logic um
uh probably dates from the 1920s when
things like truth tables were invented
by people like post and wittgenstein and
and so on
um uh brandon tells me that uh he wants
to see a
kind of after a hundred years it's time
to revise
the way that we think about and teach
logic and he thinks that the uh
the core of logic should not be uh so
much the structure of truth tables but
more
a kind of an approach that's more based
on probability
and more based on the kind of algebraic
analysis of probabilistic expressions
um and so he is planning to write a
um a computational textbook along those
lines
he created uh quite a while ago a
package called pr
sat which is a welcome language package
um
and uh uh he's been using that for
for uh research and education for for
many years now
i think for me looking through
brandon's list of publications i saw one
which was about computational
metaphysics
and i've i've been saying for a while
that for every x
there either will be or uh there either
is or will be a computational
x and i think brandon back um maybe it
was 2007
put his stake in the ground for being
perhaps the first person to uh
to coin the term computational
metaphysics um
in in in print um our next uh
innovator award goes to brandon
feitelson
thanks so much stephen really an honor
thank you
okay um our next award goes to fagelio
gomez
and so vergelio and us
is a sense a a coveted story
for helio did his bachelor's degree and
master's degree at texas tech university
and then
working on solid mechanics
and ended up using wolfram language and
mathematica
uh to develop a uh method for
improving kind of the the solving of
partial differential equations
and flexible structures and structures
with cracks
he um being able to find
semi-analytical solutions as i
understand it
for figuring out vibrations of materials
like that
greatly improving on the kind of
numerical methods that had previously
been used
but uh then vergilio uh whose mechanical
engineer by by training
um uh started working at quality
aspirators
um and using wolfram language and
mathematica
as this tool of choice for a whole
variety of projects uh
from um facial reconstruction for custom
face shields
um to other things and when when covert
hit
one of the products uh for helios
company
um was a uh is something
for dentistry um as uh
one may know there are two meanings to
the word calculus one of them is the uh
the thing that um leibniz and newton and
so on invented
the other is the the the kind of
stone-like stuff that builds up on one's
teeth
uh the the small stone um uh
was the original meaning of the word
calculus and the one from which
the idea of counting and calculation
came and that led to the
the calculus of leibniz and newton and
so on but uh anyway for helio
was involved with the other kind of
calculus and in particular with um
ultrasonic scalers the kind of thing
that um
allow you to to to clean calculus
off a tooth and uh apparently one of the
one of the main issues i
uh i guess i'm not surprised by this one
of the main issues with an ultra solid
scaler
that's scraping stuff off a tooth is
that it gets really really hot
and the way you prevent it from uh uh
from
the the way that you cool it down is by
spraying water
and when you spray water you get a bunch
of water droplets and when
the uh pandemic hit having water
droplets near mouths
was really a bad thing and so a solution
had to be found
um for uh uh to avoid
the the to avoid the this spray of water
drops apparently um
uh there's a notion of uh four-handed
dentistry which means both the dentist
and the hygienist being there and the
hygienist uh
potentially um uh sucking all those
water drops away but
there's a great desire to be able to do
two-handed dentistry particularly if you
want fewer people in the office
in the time of pandemic and for that you
need some more automated way
to to clear that whole spray out out of
the way
and what for helio did was to
use um and this is this is a a project
of the moment so to speak
um was to use uh wolfram language
uh image processing um and there are
some pictures actually illustrating it
uh use wolfram language image processing
to be able to figure out
uh was it possible to to suction in
this spray of aerosol droplets um and he
did that by
by literally taking images um like the
one on the left there and counting drops
thousands and thousands of drops and
figuring out
um using wolfram language uh doing an
analysis
which has led to successful deployment
of a product that um lets dentists get
back to work
and um uh do ultrasonic scaling
and uh and clean our teeth so
our next uh innovator award goes to
vagelio gomez
thank you so much steven it's it's an
honor
thanks well our next innovator award of
the evening
goes to greg hurst of united
therapeutics corporation
um i actually know greg quite well
because uh greg worked at wolf in
research for a number of years
and let me let me tell you a little bit
of that story so
uh greg studied mathematics at
university of illinois
and computer science got his master's
degree in mathematics at purdue
and then in 2015 joined wolf and
research
and uh uh was
involved in mathematics uh development
for wolfram alpha
and creating some of the
very popular uh kinds of step-by-step
computation
um that we provide to
to students in um in wolfen alpha um
greg also uh was working
on 3d printing and on the computational
geometry of 3d printing in fact for a
while
uh greg worked in the kernel development
group on computational geometry
before eventually getting pulled back
into doing um
a more educational mathematics
development for from alpha
and i should say that as part of of
greg's work on kind of the educational
side of
technology he's involved in our summer
camp
and was the uh academic director of our
summer camp for a couple of years
and i had the pleasure of working with
him on figuring out
lots of interesting uh high school
student
summer project uh kinds of proposals and
so on
but um uh on the side greg
was working on computational geometry
and in particular
on the 3d printing of very filamentous
structures it's not an easy thing to
when when you when you're going to 3d
print something there are a bunch of
physical constraints associated with how
you can actually build up
that thing that you're printing for
example it better be the case
that you can't you can't print something
that's going to be sort of uh
suspended in mid-air um at least not
unless you build supports that you like
to have to remove
and when you're building a kind of a
complicated filamentous structure
you have to make sure that it's possible
to get each filament
each each piece of the structure
actually built without the print head
running into things and without
all kinds of other problems like that
well greg did some some uh some nice
work on that and published some papers
about it
and uh was discovered by a company
called united therapeutics
which had the very ambitious project of
print a human lung
uh united therapeutics is the latest
venture of uh martine rothblatt who is
uh
famous for sirius xm radio and for
um uh uh going from from satellites
to uh to drug development and uh uh
executing a series of very implausible
um kinds of projects just my kinds of
projects uh but they're now
um working on um on on the project
of printing a um a human lung and greg
was brought in as the computational
geometry and mathematical
talent to make it possible to print a
human lung what's involved in printing a
human line
well ultimately there's a there's a a
framework that's made of cartilage and
um
the concept is to print that framework
made of cartilage
and then progressively uh wash it with
different kinds of cells
to build up the actual uh biological
structure of cellular structure
for the lung and our lungs uh are a very
interesting mathematical structure
they're kind of a binary tree structure
and they're a binary tree that you know
we have two lungs and then it branches
again and then it branches again and
actually branches 23 times
um until it gets down to the point where
the sort of distance from an
airway to um uh to to the blood is
is just 200 nanometers so the challenge
of united therapeutics and
and greg's work is to get to the point
where you can print
the cartilage all the way down to that
kind of scale
and i think i i realized uh talking to
greg today
that greg is probably the world's only
lung designer
he's the only person who gets to figure
out uh
what that structure for a mathematical
point of view should be like
because to some extent one needs in
building an artificial lung
to imitate the biology so that uh so
that it's possible to be
to be used in us humans but also one
gets to improve on the biology
and actually solve engineering problems
in different ways and as i said i think
greg is the
unique example in today's world of a uh
a lung designer and uh we certainly wish
him
um the best of luck in in being able to
get to the point
of um of having an actual operable
uh artificial lung um and i think we had
a picture here
yes okay i think i think that's a that's
a a printed
heart not a printed lung and i think the
technology there is i think that was
during the time when greg was thinking
of printing things out of sugar
um and that's that's different from the
from the current plan
but that's an indication of the kind of
thing that um uh
that is is being done so i'm pleased to
present
our next innovator award to um greg
hurst
thanks stephen it's a real honor thank
you
our next innovator award of the evening
goes to ambar jain
of the indian institute of science
education
and research in bhopal india
and uh ambar like so many fine people
started life as a physicist first uh
getting a bachelor's a master's degree
from indian
institute of technology in kanpur and
then getting a phd at mit
uh followed by uh post-doctoral research
at carnegie mellon
his uh his phd project was about qcd
studying oh it's he studied penguin
diagrams
cool okay in the heart of kind of
phenomenological qcd
um but uh now
he is um he's been using language and
mathematica
um in lots of different projects not
only in physics
but also in the process of education
i recently started a new physics course
with computational thinking using
wolfram language
but one of his big projects
has been the creation of a system called
examineer
which is an assessment engine for um
for assessing students at his
institution
and um one of the challenges
is um that there's a sort of continual
arms race i have i have this feeling
that it's a
it's more challenging in india than
other places because somehow
the students are more creative there in
in the arms race between
um being able to do uh sort of correct
assessments and having students
uh cheat in one way or another uh what
ambar has done
is to build a system uh based on woven
language
using our cloud technology to create
an assessment system where different
students
are able to be randomly fed in real time
different variants of exercises and
where it's possible to have
essentially every exercise becomes a
little
program and the educators who are
creating
these tests are writing not just
a test but a little micro algorithm to
represent the test
and then ambar's system examineer
is able to take that micro algorithm and
deploy it through the cloud
two different students who are who are
taking these tests
and then be able to uh to aggregate the
results together
and uh he's able to do the analysis to
find out
that yes um the students really it
really is working that um these students
are not
able to copy off each other or all these
other kinds of things
um because of the kind of uh
computational there's a sort of the
computational
approach to assessment um that involves
uh
uh all this some uh kind of
real-time randomization of um uh of of
what's being assessed
all right our next next award goes to
ambar jain
so our next award goes to alma olmos
in monterey mexico and um omar
has been using our technology
mathematica
since version 2 since 1991 when
uh he was um uh studying uh plasma
physics
and doing research as part of his
undergraduate studies
in in monterey then
for his phd he used
orphan language to uh develop a model
for photon effects and nanostructures um
at that time using mathematica eight
which
to us today seems seems so long ago
but he created a platform
for doing numerical analysis of photon
effects and nanostructures
which was then able to be used by a
future students
working on similar projects since 2005
he's been the academic director of the
science department
at itesm toluca and has been using
wolfram language and mathematica
to create courses in mathematics physics
and applied engineering
and his university has altogether 26
campuses
with nearly 70 000 students so very
large population
he's been responsible uh for uh
one of the things that um omar has been
doing recently that um i thought was
particularly interesting
is the use of uh wolverine language as a
tool for doing the analysis of
educational analytics
and uh his particular concern has been
optimizing the way that
the large number of students that go
through his institution
uh interact with the institution and
optimizing the outcomes
for their educational uh achievement
um at the institution and he's been able
to collect
all sorts of data one very interesting
kind of data that i simply had never
heard of people collecting for
educational analytics
is biometrics data uh things like heart
rate
uh data for for students and so on
and uh he's been using wolfram language
um as a way to analyze that data um i
think that that will be um
uh that that i'm i have no doubt that
that will lead to all sorts of
interesting insights
um in uh and uh uh successes for
students
in his university and beyond i think
that the um
i'm i'm very curious to know which
classes
will cause whether whether um i'm not
sure if
omar is teaching classes himself but if
he is it'll be interesting to know
whether his students
um uh if he looks at things like heart
rate and and stress some
uh you know skin conductivity and so on
at a biometric level
um that's a that's a much more precise
version of rate your
rate my professors um to to be able to
actually see biometrically one student's
responses to uh
uh to to a class in any case i'm
happy to present our next innovator
award
to omar olmos thank you great thank you
very much stephen
my pleasure our next award goes to
gustavo
restrepo who has a startup company
um exegetica in bogota colombia
although he is currently in moscow
russia so
gustavo studied chemical engineering
in um in colombia and then for his phd
moved to moscow to study industrial
thermal engineering
and was there introduced to a
mathematical morphing language
for studying complex phenomena for heat
and mass transfer
and chemical reactions inside
thermo-chemical
reactors and so on so gustavo then
worked as a process engineer in the
energy and chemical industry
uh using wolfram language to model heat
loss
and control loops that are involved in
in those industries he's done a lot of
different things with with wolfram
language
from an early project here
unusual uh topic of um
the creation of a handbook for the
reduction of smell emissions
for the national poultry industry
federation in colombia
together with uh heat and mass transfer
calculations for methane steam
conversion facilities
um all sorts of uh uh different
kinds of things diesel tanks all sorts
of things
i think that the um uh the the the
general theme
is uh that gustavo has been involved in
the oil and gas industry
in kind of the i think primarily the
part of it
that goes from get the oil out of the
ground to get it to a to
separation into and then to a refinery
and so on
in recent times he's been
using also from system modeler and has
developed a library of hydrodynamic
components
to be used in the oil and gas industry
as components to be used in the
system modeling and ordinary
differential equation solving that
system modeler
uh makes possible um also in in
the oil and gas industry is often one
that has some all sorts of interesting
technology used in it
and gustavo has been bringing some of
that
in developing for example a pump system
uh metamodel
um designed using a trained neural
network so uh his his business
aims to um implement um
to to use uh wolfram language
for oil and gas purposes in latin
america
and um it's it's obvious that um he's
been doing a lot of interesting things
in that area
so i'm happy to present our
award to gustavo restrepo
thank you very much stefan it's very
important for me and for
exercise to get that hour thank you
our next award goes to ariel sapolvada
ariel has been involved with the um
wolfram language
community for uh a long time
um he uh got his bachelor's degree a
master's degree at university of puerto
rico
his phd at virginia tech applying
uh on on quality control and um applying
i think control theory
to to um uh to quality control
so he was first introduced to orphan
language through mathematica 2.2 in 1993
while he was a student at virginia tech
um
and uh he's used it ever since
for all kinds of different things ariel
has attended
many conferences over the years um he
was
for a while a professor at the
university of puerto rico
um then a quality engineer at hp
and then someone then was involved in
in doing data analytics for retail data
analysis
for hp products and um uh
for the last um 10 years or so i think
um he's been
a consultant uh working on bringing
wolfram language technology
um to data analytics in a variety of
settings
and he's particularly uh known to us for
the creation
of um a series of products
that um he's been delivering to to a
variety of clients over the years
he has a a new product um that
he's been putting finishing touches to
uh called d4cr that is very strongly
based
on that that is a welcome language
product
um and he's i think one of the sort of
very strong
users of our symbolic user interface
technology
and uh he was telling me he's really
happy that in addition to maintaining
compatibility
of our main functions in our language
we're also
maintaining compatibility of the
operation of the symbolic user interface
because that's what his products are
based on and uh
his uh his main objective is
to take data that could come from
databases and so on
and to find really elegant ways
to present data um in ways that are
useful to management
in in companies in a variety of
different industries
he's also started now doing some natural
language processing
for queries that can be asked uh on
from databases uh going through his
dynamic technology
and he was just telling me that um uh
he's
just started with his new product he has
his first couple of customers
um one in the manufacturing sector um
one in the uh primate research sector
where uh he was telling me that the the
data associated with primate research
can be messy and i was
i was just wondering whether that's
actually monkeys throwing food at each
other
or whether that's more a reference to um
characteristics of the
of the underlying data and that might be
in uh
you know access databases or something
at this time but um
in that case ariel and his new product
are um
uh on course to make that beautiful and
to really
deliver the um uh the capabilities of
of uh of of language and settings like
that i think that
ariel as many people this evening uh
sort of uh
give evidence for my um uh my sort of
characterization of what we do
as kind of bringing artifacts from the
from the future
to and applying them to sort of
practical uh
uh applications today so our next
innovator award goes to ariel sapolvada
thanks thank you
thank you
our next uh innovator award this evening
um goes to uh ghee determined
who is at the university of costa rica
he uh started life
as a physicist uh got his phd
at um university of paris saclay
um back in 1977 and actually ghee's
advisor
was a person called mary guyard mary kay
guyard
who's a physicist who i knew back in the
days when i was doing physics and he
told me
he was actually her first student
although he didn't know that
until she published an autobiography
just
a couple of years ago and uh he said if
he'd known that he was going to be her
first student he might not have picked
her as
his advisor but i'm sure i'm sure it
worked out well anyway
um ghee uh started off studying
um uh using essentially particle physics
methods to think about
nuclear physics and to think about
questions like
whether forces between neutrons and
neutrons nuclear forces between neutrons
and neutrons
are the same as nuclear forces between
neutrons and protons and so on
then went on and has done many other
things in physics
publishing many papers on uh
structure of strongly interacting
particles um and
also ground unified theories and so on i
kind of uh
i think there's there's kind of a theme
that seems to run through gee's work
that he's been involved in strong
interactions nuclear forces and so on
in a variety of different periods in the
development of particle physics
and in recent times he's been involved
in the
idea of using the um
holographic principles and adf cft these
correspondences between
general relativity and conformal field
theory to um
to find a new way to study qcd to study
the theory of quarks and gluons
um the light front uh holographic qcd
and using that as a way to investigate
uh
investigate strong interactions but in
the middle
of all of uh gee's physics work
he's also done a lot of a lot of work
on the practical side of
computing and um science policy in costa
rica i
i believe he's known in costa rica as
the father of the costa rican internet
he was responsible back in the in the
1990s
um for uh um bringing
uh uh bringing the internet to
universities in costa rica
apparently in those days it was a a
story there weren't
um uh submarine cables and so on with
fiber optics and so on
so it was a story of using satellites
and such like to be able to deliver
internet to the different universities
around costa rica
uh i should say that he started um uh
using language and mathematica about 20
years ago
um uh for his physics and for many other
many other kinds of things one of the um
parts of um of ghee's uh
background is that um for um
he was the um director the computer
center at his university
but then he became the minister of
science and technology
in 2000 uh for the country of costa rica
um and at that time uh continued his
efforts
to uh uh really bring uh bring the
internet and computer technology
uh to costa rica and bring computation
to uh to the education system i believe
not only at the university level but
also
at the um uh k through 12 level
um bringing uh bringing the internet and
computation
uh to schools in costa rica so i'm happy
to uh
and i gather ghee has also been involved
in
in in working with other countries in
the in the region
connecting internet to um uh to other
countries near costa rica and so on i'm
i'm curious about some of the
engineering challenges
particularly in areas where there's
mountains and jungles and all kinds of
things like that about what's actually
involved in
in getting the internet from here to
there um it's a
it's an important and probably very
challenging thing to do
well uh our next award goes to uh
ghee determined our next award goes to
william turkell
of university of western ontario i've
been aware of william's work
for um for a little while he's a
professor of history
and he is an example of uh
another person who's bringing artifacts
from the future to the present day
and delivering computation um to the
humanities
as a computational history and other
kinds of uh
as a as an early uh member of the
of the what i'm sure will be a rapidly
growing field of computational
humanities
he um started using orphan language
when he was working on his master's
degree in linguistics at university of
british columbia
where he had also gotten a bachelor's
degree in psychology
then at that time he was
working on mathematical models of
language acquisition and language change
but he's jumped around doing a lot of
different kinds of things he got his
another master's degree in brain and
cognitive science at mit
and then a phd also at mit in history
anthropology
and uh sds science technology and
society i think that stands for
i'm i'm interested to see some williams
publications
um because they're so uh so diverse for
example one about um
um how shocking experiments with
strongly electric
fish powered scientific discovery
or the uh um
another one on rethinking inventories in
the digital age the case of the old
bailey
another one on using computer vision to
explore sources in the history of stage
magic
so i i can i think even from a distance
i can tell that william is having fun
um being somebody who's delivering
artifacts from the future to the present
day
uh sort of uh picking off some of the
terrific things that are possible to do
with computational methods
in the humanities i think he's been
particularly involved
in doing text analysis
he was saying that he was pleased to see
that we now have pdf
import working because that's important
when he wants to analyze
uh 4 000 books to study
uh he was saying that he's interested in
studying things like footnoting
um in different kinds of books and um
was saying that uh academics and this is
a big surprise
are sloppier than you might imagine in
making their footnotes
it's um one of the things in addition to
uh
williams books on things like uh
electric fish
um the uh the book that um i'm most
familiar with is his book on digital
research methods with mathematica
came out in 2015 um it's a
open textbook um that uh
covers lots of kinds of things for the
digital humanities
in text analysis and beyond and i kind
of get the impression
that william likes to use as many
artifacts
from the future as possible in in the
humanities
uh doing image processing machine
learning and so on he was mentioning to
me
a project taking electric circuit
diagrams
and um uh doing image processing to
analyze
uh the the history of electric circuit
design
um through uh uh through computational
means
well so uh our whoops i forgot my next
slide here
there we go there's a picture of
william's book terrific um
well our next award goes to william
turkell
thank you stephen
okay last but not least for this evening
our final award goes to
um mike weimascritch
uh scotch sorry the uh from the
university of minnesota
and um mike
tells me he kind of started off as a
high school teacher
then went back to get his phd in
mathematics
at uh university of minnesota and uh
since that time
in 2007 he's been involved in
teaching uh in in the process of
teaching math
um at um uh university of minnesota
um and in particular in um
the the placement of students incoming
students
at the university placing them into the
correct pre-calculus and below
kinds of mathematics courses and so
uh for that purpose he's been involved
in creating
a big system actually i should mention
that um
mike mike um advises math majors
uh at university of minnesota um but his
biggest project has been
i believe it's called the moles project
um
uh to do with the um placement
of of um of incoming students at the
university of minnesota
and uh for that he's been working with
our technical services group
to build this large-scale system um
that uh is um is
based on uh wolfram language running in
the cloud
this is uh serving about 1400 students
per year
it's uh able to provide
detailed analysis that has been
apparently very successful at
matching up students with appropriate
courses
at the university and i think there's um
a um
a lot of interesting features in the
system
it's some the creation of questions has
now gotten to the point where
it's just the instructor can write a
question in a notebook
and apparently
it's kind of like have an idea while
you're
you know writing to work
if you're doing that outside of pandemic
times
kind of um uh put it in your
custom notebook and uh have have that
idea turn into something that can
actually show up in the
in the placement exam uh very quickly
so it's um it's always um it's always
great to see our technology used
in these kind of um uh large-scale
education applications
and uh pleased to present this
innovator award uh to mike weimerskirch
thank you very much stephen for this
honor thank you
all right well that is everyone here
as i say my um i i wanted to to give you
guys a little bit of insight about some
uh the the some of the things that uh
some of these
these uh award winners have been doing i
personally find it really interesting
learning about
all of these different kinds of uh uses
of our technology
and i find it um quite inspiring
actually to see the diversity
um of different uh of different uses
that
um the things we've been spending all
this effort developing
uh can get put to so thank you very much
to
to all of our innovators here tonight i
think that's um
that's it for our innovator award
program